all right ted well 2021 turns out has
been a pretty good year when it comes to
people getting married as many were
postponed in 2020 and weddings of course
are big business and the bridal
spectacular in downtown las vegas is
ready to help couples tie the knot
victoria saha takes a look at the
current trends and why we continue to be
a popular destination wedding spot the
wedding industry is getting back on its
feet after a halt last year making the
bridal spectacular expo at world market
center the perfect comeback for vendors
to meet potential clients so i'm seeing
a lot of
we won't wait anymore kind of trends
happening that is the mindset for nicole
mcdown and stephen wheat they set a date
for june 3 2022. i don't know whether
next june i'm gonna have to wear a face
mask or not and that's not something i
want to do but we've invested so much
and saved the dates and looking at
invitations that changing the date
really isn't
a good option either with the
uncertainty of the pandemic the couple
has to shorten their guest list from 100
to 60. we're seeing more micro weddings
engaged
elopements
minimoni's like there's lots of cute
names for it but just smaller more
intimate weddings a 2021 trend that
dress stores are seeing are these little
white dresses david's bridal tells me
that they are selling a hundred of these
a month because of how lightweight they
are and it's easy to travel with for a
destination wedding or a quick allotment
here in clark county more than 45
thousand marriage licenses were given
this year a popular month was april with
almost 8 thousand last year at that time
401
and the most popular date this year was
4-3-2-1
with
972 couples either way las vegas is
prepared as many reference it as the
wedding capital of the world we have the
staff we have mobile ministers mobile
photography victoria saha 8 news now
clark county anticipates they will give
out more than 80 000 marriage licenses
this year the last time we saw those
numbers that was back in 2016. the
bridal spectacular expo starts at six
o'clock tonight goes until 10 then
there's going to be another chance to go
tomorrow from 11 to 4. again it's over
at world market one lucky couple will be
able to win a twenty five hundred dollar
custom made ring but they must dig
through a seven tier cake with other
competing couples to find that hidden
ring brian that is the funnest messiest
game